HOLMAN WANG: Hi, everyone.
My name is Holman Wang,
and my presentation today
is called From Bar
Wars to Star Wars--
How a Lawyer Came to Create
Kids Books in a Galaxy Far,
Far Away.
So today, I am going to talk
a little bit about my work,
and I'm going to talk a little
bit about my career transition
as well.
The reference to bar
wars, of course--
I used to fight many
a battle at the bar.
I used to be a lawyer.
And in Canada, we
actually have to gown up
for certain court proceedings.
And so these are fairly
preposterous photos,
but the only ones I had of
me actually wearing a gown.
So there I am.
But now, I am no
longer a lawyer.
I quit in December 2012,
and now I do kids books.
And the most recent series
of books that I've done
is called "Star
Wars Epic Yarns."
where we-- we being my brother
and I, my brother Jack--
we abridge each of the
original "Star Wars" movies
into word primers that are
just 12 words and 12 images.
And we have a particular
illustration technique
which we use, which is
called needle felting.
And I will talk more
about that later.
But very quickly
right now, there
is the cast of
characters-- most the cast
of characters for the books
that are made out of wool.
And then like I said,
we abridge the books
to 12 words and
12 illustrations.
So a typical spread will look
something like this-- captain,
and there's Han Solo and Greedo.
In our world, Han
shoots first, of course.
In fact, Greedo doesn't
have a gun at all.
And here's another
image of Jabba the Hutt
paired with the word "monster."
And the spread of the
books looks like this.
So this is how the
actual books look.
And they are board book
format, so nice and chunky,
fairly indestructible
for young children.
Now, I'm going to back up
the narrative a little bit
to tell you a little
bit about my life.
My brother I were
born in Taiwan.
And we came to Canada when
we were one and a half,
and this is our first
birthday in Canada.
And we were big "Star Wars"
fans when we were kids.
So here's a picture of Jack
and I. Jack has the lightsaber,
and I'm in the kung fu pose.
I like to think of this
picture as Crouching Tiger,
not-so-hidden lightsaber.
And it's funny, because I
was at a school presentation,
and I said, well, this is sort
of kung fu meet Star Wars.
And one of the little
kids said, no, no, no.
That's not kung fu.
That's the emperor
zapping Luke Skywalker
with his force of
lightning, which
I thought was quite clever,
except I didn't have the heart
to tell him that the
"Return of the Jedi"
had not actually come
out by this point.
But at any rate,
my brother and I
were always quite
artistic as young kids.
Here we are, some
random art contest.
I don't even
remember what it was.
We look fairly
enthused about winning.
I'm not sure about
that girl, though.
Fast-forwarding to high
school, here are my brother
and I coaching the grade
ten girls basketball team
to the Vancouver
city championships.
There we are in the background.
But I'll be perfectly honest.
We were probably less jock
and more Spock in high school
because we were in fact,
science fair kings.
And I don't know if that's
a good thing or a bad thing.
But we were science fair kings.
We went to the National Science
Fair in Canada four times.
And that sort of led to a
meandering wayward career
trajectory for me.
Because we did most of
our science fair projects
in plant physiology,
I wound up-- well,
I call this my over-educated
and underemployed period
of my life.
So first I went to university
originally to study biology.
But then I thought that was
not really to my interest,
so I shifted gears a little
bit and did a double major
in biology and anthropology.
And then I wasn't sure what
to do with my life after that,
so I went to get a
bachelor in education
to teach middle school.
And then after that,
I thought, well,
I don't really want
to teach either.
So I'm going to
become an architect.
That's more creative.
So I spent a year in the
architecture design program
and then decided that
wasn't for me either.
So I dropped out, and just
hung around the department
and did a master's of
architecture history
apropos of nothing
really, and then
did a number of
non-career related jobs.
And then when I was
30, decided maybe I
should get my act together and
I should go back to law school
and get my law degree,
and that was what I did.
So after I got my law degree,
I was more well-employed
than I had been in the past.
And here I am on the day
that I got called to the bar.
Strange thing happened,
though, after a couple of years
of practicing as a lawyer.
I developed a cough that
would never go away.
It would actually get worse
when I wanted to go to court,
and it was sort of some
high-stress situation.
And they tested.
The doctors tested
for tuberculosis
and asthma and heart
conditions and cancer
and all sorts of things.
At the end of the
day, the doctor
told me it was a
psychogenic cough, which
meant the genesis
was in my psyche,
or that I basically
was so depressed
or had such underlying stress
or anxiety about the career
that I had chosen that it was
manifesting itself in this way.
And so it became clear to me
that I needed to make a career
shift at some point.
I wasn't exactly sure
what that would be.
Here's my office
on the 32nd floor.
You can see that there are
a number of pieces of paper
that I've collected over
the years on the wall.
And then I brought
all those plants
in because I thought maybe
I was on the 32nd floor
and couldn't breathe because
there wasn't enough oxygen
up there.
And so anyways,
this is my office.
And it was about five
or six years ago,
and my brother came to
me one day and said,
I know I've got this
idea for kids books.
It was almost as
a joke at first,
because he wanted to abridge
theorists, like really
high-level theorists
like Freud and Jung,
and say, why don't we
make baby books for them
out of those theorists?
And it was kind of
just a joke thing.
But then we got to
talking, and then he
had a more serious
proposal, which
was why don't we
abridge classics
for very young children
in just a couple of words?
Because we had gotten very
used to reading a lot of word
primers to our very
young children.
And word primers,
they can tend to get
a little stale-- barnyard
animals, shapes, colors.
These are all very important
things, but after a while,
they're a little bit boring,
frankly, for parents.
And sometimes, the
art in the books
is also a little bit stale--
clip art or stock photography.
So here, I actually
have a picture
of a word primer, which I
didn't want to offend any North
American publishers so I've
gone to an overseas publication
here.
And it's bilingual.
And you see there's all
kinds of issues here.
Instead of "my actions,"
it says "my acting" here.
And then apparently
children grovel and creep.
And then this little
boy here in the blue box
is ready for life in
the 17th century here.
So anyways, this is
the kind of thing
that you tend to-- not always,
but very often experience
with word primers.
And we thought how can we make
word primers more exciting?
Why do they always have
to be concept books?
Why can't they be storybooks?
Why can't they have a
narrative for young children?
So that's when we came up
with the idea of needle
felting some figures.
I hope this video works.
Here's a time-lapse video.
And needle felting's a technique
where you take a loose wool
roving, and you basically
stab it again and again
with a specialized
barbed needle.
And what that does is
entangles the fibers.
And when you
entangle the fibers,
it gets firmer and
firmer, and then you
can start to sculpt with it.
So here, I've
bulked out the body,
and then now I'm
adding the details
to this particular figure,
which happens to be
Mr. Rochester from "Jane Eyre."
And we thought that
would be a great way
to illustrate children's books.
And so this is the very
first concept illustration
that we did.
This is for "Moby
Dick," and this
is Ishmeal from "Moby Dick."
And originally, it was this
idea that we might even just
use paper backgrounds
with old woodcut prints,
or maps and that kind of thing--
very gestural, very simple.
And then we also explored the
possibility of illustrating two
dimensionally with wool.
And here you can see we've
illustrated a stormy sea
in a boat that's lost.
But ultimately, we
rejected this concept
in favor of taking
the wool figures,
and either building
three-dimensional sets
for them, or taking them
actually out on location
and shooting them in
natural environments.
So or first two books
that came out in late 2012
were "Moby Dick" and
"Pride and Prejudice."
And you see, the entire book
is just 12 words and 12 images.
And here, we have
Mr. Darcy refusing
to dance with Lizzie Bennett,
and paired with the word
"mean."
There's Captain Ahab
with his peg leg
from "Moby Dick" This is
Andrei Bolkonsky and Natasha
Rostova from "War and Peace."
And that's Pierre Bezukhov
sort of looking on jealously
during the dance in
the middle there.
So the idea is that for
very young children--
and this is Jane Eyre and
Mr. Rochester kissing.
So the idea is that for
very young children,
they're just simple
word primers.
You can just illustrate
simple concepts,
simple words-- "kiss,"
"dance," that kind of thing.
As children get a
little bit older--
they're four,
five, or six-- they
become storytelling vehicles
because they're narrative.
Parents can fill in the detail.
And if you know the story,
you can fill in the details.
Even if you don't know the
story, it doesn't matter.
The idea is to use
your imaginations.
You can get your
kids to tell you
the story, what's happening
from one picture to the next.
There's no wrong way
to read our books.
So we found that as we got along
into this project of abridging
classics, the
illustrations really
got more and more involved.
Here we are building an
entire miniature forest.
And that's Tom
Sawyer and Huck Finn
in the forest for this
shot of them camping.
And sometimes, it's possible
to take things and do them
on location.
But when you have them
around a campfire,
everything has to be
at a smaller scale.
You just wind up having
to build the whole thing.
Here I am in some
very sexy hip waders
that I borrowed from
a friend, and just
got right out into the muddy
slew with a little raft.
There's Huck and Jim
from "Huckleberry Finn."
And I was able to get this shot.
So I was actually in the
slew with the camera,
frightened that I was going to
slip and lose my $1,500 camera.
But it's just all part of
trying to get the right image
for these books.
Now,it's sort of interesting
because there was this
particular trend in children's
books to really stay away from
adult themes, to
really sanitize things,
have a lot of pink bunnies and
magical unicorns and things
that are kind of
divorced from real life,
and this insulated world
of children's books.
It's illustrated perfectly
by this "New Yorker" cartoon.
There are these two kids here.
They're watching television.
There's two animals.
And there's the word
"respect" at the top.
And it says "Everything
I know about being
human I learned from animals."
And there is this kind of trend
that we have to teach lessons
through animals and through
some kind of slightly
sanitized world.
And so we're taking
a different approach.
We think that some of these
great classics, these stories
that people love, have
lessons that you can actually
share with children.
Of course, it's totally
up to the adult,
right, what you share
at any one point.
Because those lessons are not
embedded in the story per se.
There's only 12 words, right?
But kids are curious.
And my own kids
ask me questions.
We have other
parents who tell us
that they have very inquisitive
children who ask questions
about what's going on, what's
the motivation that's going on
with particular characters.
And parents can sort
of adapt their answers
to their child at
the appropriate age.
And so people seem
to like our books.
This is sort of the neatest
piece of publicity we probably
got, which is in "People"
magazine with a cover
graced with Brangelina.
And so that takes
us to 2013, when
we exhibited some of our artwork
at the Bologna Children's Book
Fair.
And that's the world's
largest book fair
where publishers and
authors, illustrators,
and agents-- the biggest book
fair for children's books.
And people go in and sell
rights and that sort of thing.
There's also an illustrator's
exhibition there,
and we were very
fortunate to have
some of our "Pride and
Prejudice" images selected
for the exhibition.
So we had a chance to go to
Italy-- used it as an excuse
to take our wives there.
And look, you don't
need to be a lawyer
to have a wonderful,
glamorous life.
You could be a
kid's Illustrator.
We could go to Italy.
This is part of how I'm selling
the career change to my wife.
But importantly,
while we were there,
we met a representative
from Chronicle Books who
took some of our
Cozy Classics back
to the head of the children's
department at Chronicle,
and she liked our
books and talked to us
about doing a new project.
And she said, well, what do
you guys interested in doing?
And we just thought,
well, why don't we
just shoot for the moon and
say "Star Wars," because--
and we grew up with "Star Wars."
This is "Star Wars" to
us, the original trilogy,
with all due respect to
the young children who
think that Jar Jar Binks
is the bee's knees.
This is "Star Wars" for us.
And Lucas Film sort of said,
hm, interesting-- 12 words,
needle felted characters.
Why don't you needle
felt something for us?
Let's see what you guys can
do in the Star Wars universe.
And so we did this.
This is our very first figure.
It's Luke in an X-wing costume,
and we sent these images
to Lucas.
And that's what sort
of got us the gig.
So now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to run through "A New
Hope" for you in 12 words
so you get a sense of
how our books actually
work cover to cover.
So here we go.
Princess.
Trouble.
Boy.
Learn.
Captain.
Space.
Help.
Garbage.
Swing.
Duel.
Fly.
And finally, heroes.
And that's "Star
Wars" in 12 words.
And so like I said, for
very young children,
it's a word primer.
They get to learn.
You get to just say, hey,
look, the spaceship is flying.
With my own children who are
three and five, we sit down
and I do my best, or
worst, Chewbacca imitation
as the case may be--
Yoda imitations,
Darth Vader impressions.
I just sort of have
some fun with it.
It's a storytelling vehicle.
And I know that lots of adults
like our books because they're
just kind of fun, and they're
ironic that a story that they
love has been abridged
into 12 words.
So they keep it around
as a coffee table book.
So now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to just talk
a little bit more
about the process of
creating the books.
What you didn't see in the
video is that the figures all
start with a wire armature.
So that helps us, one,
get the general size
of the figure mapped
out beforehand.
All of these "Star Wars" figures
are done in the exact one
to seven scale so that
all the relative heights
of the characters are correct.
But more importantly,
the wire armature
allows the figures to
be posed and reposed.
And then you can put them
into the various action poses.
So then you see, as you wind the
roving around and you stab it,
it starts to entangle and you
start to bulk up the bodies.
And then here, you see
a half completed Luke.
We had one question early
on that troubled us,
which was how we're
going to deal with all
these elaborate "Star
Wars" costume changes
and keep character continuity.
Because we knew we couldn't do
a whole bunch of different Luke
heads and make them
look exactly the same.
So we came up with a
system of removable heads
so that Luke's
head could actually
pop off and go to another
body with another costume.
And for those of you
who are in the room,
I can do a quick demonstration.
See this-- Luke's head
just comes right off right
here like that.
And then the storm
trooper head comes off.
And then you see, now Luke
is ready for the Death Star,
you see.
So that saved us a lot
of time because we didn't
have to destroy costumes.
But at the same time,
we were able to maintain
character continuity and do
elaborate costume changes.
Other figures like R2-D2
started off, again, very simply.
This cross piece is where
his legs would fit into.
And then you'd bulk up his
body into this cylinder, felt
the top part, and top part
just fits onto the wire that's
sticking out.
And then his head can rotate.
And then we had to do
slightly different techniques
for the legs because
needle felting
is very good for sort
of soft, curvy elements.
It's harder to create
hard edges with wool.
So what we did is
we took craft felt,
which you can get at any kind
of craft store that kids cut up
and make two-dimensional
illustrations with-- we took
that craft felt and glued
it into layers in order
to ultimately achieve the
hard edges of R2-D2's legs.
Now, for Darth Vader, we
knew that we wanted his eyes
to have a different texture,
so they couldn't be wool.
We wanted them to catch and
reflect light a little bit
differently.
So I was sitting around
in my studio one day
and thinking about what that
could be, that material.
And I saw a beer can
just sitting there.
And it was painted black,
and I thought, oh, I
could just cut up some of this
aluminum from the beer can.
So then I cut out some ovals and
glued that on top of the wool.
And Darth Vader literally
has beer goggles on,
but it does a very effective
job of capturing the light.
We really wanted to be true to
"Star Wars," get things right.
Because we know that "Star
Wars" fans are very discerning.
So Princess Leia
actually features
nine different hairstyles
through the three books.
Because of course, her
hairstyles are famous,
and we had to get
them all right.
All the humanoid figures are
wool through and through.
Some of the larger figures
start off with a Styrofoam core,
just because it would save
hours and hours of this sort
of felting and bulking up.
So we would put Styrofoam
boards together,
glue them into a large
block, and then we
would start shaving it
down a hot melting tool.
And then just sort of shave
it down, shave it down.
And you know who
this is going to be.
And there I am with the
studio set up with a visit
from my children.
And you've already seen this
shot with Jabba the Hutt.
The same technique was
used for the tauntaun.
And there, I bought a
little plastic tauntaun
to try to copy the proportions.
And there's the final
tauntaun with Luke on it.
And then I took this out to a
local ski hill to shoot this.
And it's kind of an
illusion, because he
looks like he's on a
sort of rocky outcropping
and there's snow on it.
In fact, it's just
a snow pile that's
been pushed to the side of
the parking lot by a plow.
And the parts that look
like rocks, it's just dirt.
It's just dirty snow.
But it creates the illusion of
it being like a rocky hillside.
It worked very effectively.
Some of the other sets required
very elaborate cut pieces.
And so I would start
with a paper template.
For example, I would
draw it out to know
exactly what I was cutting.
And in this case, this is part
of the blockade runner scene
where Princess Leia is
putting the Death Star
plans into R2-D2.
And I just used pliable foam and
cut out holes on the top level,
and then put another
level in the back
to create these
indentations, sprayed
the foam with a metallic
paint and started
to set those pieces up,
tested some lighting, and then
basically just kind of--
A lot of these shots involve
a lot of MacGyver-ing
because you're just
kind of figuring it out
as you go along.
You need some red lighting
in the background.
You need light at this angle.
You can see the front light,
it's a little bit too wide.
So I've put tin foil on to
narrow the focus of the light
at the front because
they don't really
make lights to work
at this small scale--
or at least I haven't found any.
So I sort of jimmy the
equipment that I have.
And that was the princess scene.
The most complicated
set to build
was possibly the
blockade runner hallway
because it had a lot of curved
elements, which I had to make
out of, again, pliable foam.
And so I cut these elements.
To give it some rigidity,
I used some foam core.
And then I would put
together a column like this.
And then I would put together
a whole number of columns.
And then I would start
to assemble them.
Add the consoles.
Add the detailing, the flooring.
Also needed to add some
lighting panels for the ceiling.
And then this is the
finished hallway.
And then I put the figures in.
And you can there's
all the top lighting.
And then that's the final shot.
So the whole process of
making these three books
took us about a year.
We did about five
months of needle felting
before we even did any
set making or photography.
And that, we've probably got
most of the felt figures,
but by all means,
not all the figures
done in the first five months.
So some of the sets also
started off with Styrofoam.
And then what we
would do is we would
add quick-set
concrete texturize it.
And then we would
paint that concrete,
and this is that
Ben Kenobi's hut.
And then we put the figures in.
And this is the "learn"
image that you saw earlier.
This is another Styrofoam
and concrete set.
This is a cantina booth.
And sometimes,
some of these sets
call for very
simple electronics.
There's a table lamp
in this instance.
And so here are
the figures posed.
And there's some lighting
through the little small window
at the back.
And then ultimately, this
is the shot that results.
And because these
books are supposed
to be for very young
children potentially,
we did make some modifications.
We didn't want any drawn guns.
So as I mentioned
earlier, Hans definitely
shoots first in our
version, because Greedo
doesn't have a gun at all.
So he's just sort of
pointing somewhat menacing.
But he actually has a gun in the
movie, but there's no gun here.
Some of the other, this is the
beginnings of the Millennium
Falcon cockpit.
And it's just balsa wood.
These colored circles at the top
are actually embroidery hoops
that you would get at a
store like Michael's if you
like to do needlepoint work.
The wood circle at the
bottom is something
that someone might
make a wreath with.
So when we were
making these books,
there was a lot of walking
around hardware stores
and craft stores and just
looking at objects and going,
can that be something else?
There was a lot
of plumbing parts
that I was looking at in
hardware stores, thinking,
could they become space
components of spaceships?
So it was sort of fun and
also a bit of a challenge
sometimes to find things
that could serve as a prop.
So then the interior of
this cockpit gets painted.
Some of the metallic elements
at the very top, those
are like model train parts.
And then this is
just a test shot
of putting the Death
Star into the shot.
And then ultimately, the setup
started to look like this.
And it's a little bit difficult
to see from this slide,
but what's behind the
Death Star is actually
a piece of black card stock
with holes punched in it.
And there's Christmas
lights behind it
so that in the final
shot when you see stars,
those are not
computer-illustrated.
Those are actual lights
coming through the card stock.
For the trash compactor
scene, I actually
had to get an
iron-based paint that
would rust when you applied
an oxidizing solution.
So this is the paint in
the process of rusting.
It starts off gray.
And then when you add the
solution, it starts to rust.
And then ultimately, the
walls look like that.
And then I added
the various pieces
for the garbage-- pieces of foam
and rubber and metal and so on.
Oh, actually, just
there's some dirt
on the walls that's
sort of dripping down,
and I just wound up put coffee
rinds and a little bit of oil
on to the walls.
And the oil actually started
seeping into the walls
and spreading a little bit.
So I had to get my shot
quickly before that oil just
got all over the place.
So that was kind
of a-- at first,
I thought it was a
clever move, and then
kind of backfired on me.
So these are things that
you kind of figure out
as you go along.
This is the shot
of Luke and Leia
swinging across the
Death Star where
there's the broken bridge.
And this is a shot from behind
the Death Star walls, which
are all backlit with lights.
And there, as you can see,
in the background, Luke
and Leia hanging by string.
So they are still,
and they don't
move when I'm taking the shot.
But as you can see
from this angle,
I built the whole Death Star
wall on a platform with wheels
so that when I
take the shot, I'm
actually pushing the Death Star
wall to create a slight blur.
So that there is this
kind of motion effect.
And it's much more dramatic
in the next sequence
here with the X-wing fighter.
First of all, the
X-wing fighters,
or the spaceships
in general, were
too delicate to needle
felt in their entirety.
So we built those
out of cardboard,
and then put craft felt
over top of the surfaces.
And here are the components
of the X-wing fighter.
Then I took the fuselage,
put it on some pegs,
and then started
adding the wings.
And there's the
completed X-wing fighter.
And then for the
Death Star wall,
I knew I just needed to create
a bunch of light and shadow.
It didn't necessarily need
to look like the Death Star
per se.
So I just took a whole
bunch of Styrofoam
from electronics packages or
whatever and other garbage
and just glued it onto
this large Styrofoam board,
painted it all gray,
and then set it up
behind the X-wing fighter.
And then did a
long exposure shot.
And then when that
shot was taken,
I pulled the wall very quickly.
And then the final
effect was like this.
So it creates the
illusion of flight.
And then digitally,
I removed those two
pegs so those aren't seen.
Here is the Dagobah set.
And this was kind of fun
because, well, first of all,
I got to get some tree branches
and put some soil down.
I took dried leaves and I
actually put them in a blender
to scale them down
into little pieces.
Took a bunch of yarn,
painted them green to create
all those hanging vines.
But the really fun
part was there's
a couple of baking
dishes you can
see in a shot around the edges.
And I filled those
with hot water,
and then I put dry
ice in them to create
the misty effects of Dagobah.
And I have a video here
that I'll show you.
Hope this works.
Nope, let's see.
Let's try that again.
Oh, that video's
not cooperating.
So at any rate, we've
got a still shot here.
And you can see that the dry ice
vapors are sort of coming out.
The dry ice vapors
are heavier than air,
so they just kind of
roll across the surface.
And it creates that misty
atmosphere of Dagobah.
And there's the final shot.
And it's a very subtle touch.
You only see a little bit
of the mist at the bottom.
But again, it's not
computer-generated.
Our goal is to try to
do things in camera.
This is just the setup for
the shuttle Tydirium shot
where they're flying
to the Endor moon.
And this is the final set.
And there's the final image
with all the characters
in the shuttle.
For the Endor scenes,
I tried to get a tree
stump from the forest
and bring it home.
If anyone's ever
tried to do that,
it's actually a very
difficult task-- one,
because there are not tree
stumps lying around for you
to pick up and take home.
And if you do see a
whole fallen tree,
it'll take you five days to cut
through it without a chainsaw.
So I decided to just build
my own cedar tree with cedar
bark and just a Styrofoam base.
And that wound up in
a number of shots.
This is the interior
of the Ewok village.
And here I am using real fire.
There's little candle
at the top by wicket.
And the fire in
the middle, there's
a couple of candles in there.
And the final shot here.
The word is "storytime."
This is from "Return
of the Jedi."
And then here's the tree for
the outdoor scene in the Ewok
village.
And for this scene here
where Luke tells Leia
that they're related,
they're brother and sister,
I actually feel my entire
studio slash office
with incense smoke,
just to create
a little bit of that haze
that's seen in the movie.
So we did whatever we could
to try to recreate the tone
and feel of the movies.
And those were the studio shots.
And we also did some
location shooting as well.
I already showed you the
shot of the tauntaun.
Here I am on Mount Seymour
doing another Hoth scene.
There's the felted
Luke in the foreground.
There's a cardboard snow speeder
that's crashed, which we built.
And then for AT-AT,
we thought, well,
we're not going to
reinvent the wheel.
Let's just use that wonderful
Kenner plastic AT-AT that we
all remember from the '80s.
And we got one of those, set
that up in the background.
And then the final
shot looks like this.
And I think with blurring
and people's understanding
of the scale of
the AT-AT, people
are imagining there's a
big menacing machine off
in the distance.
All right, here's the cover
for "Return the Jedi."
And those are, again--
the speeder bikes
were too hard to make, so we
decided to use toys again.
And then we found
perfectly scaled ones.
And we put our felt figures
on the speeder bikes,
set those up in the
forest, and that
wound up being the cover
of "Return of the Jedi."
And I live in Vancouver.
My brother, he is a
writing professor.
He lives in Ithaca, New York.
But we decided, well,
we need some desert.
And there's no desert in
Vancouver or New York.
So we decided to come down
to California find it.
And this, in fact, is
the imperial sand dunes
where George Lucas filmed
parts of "Return of the Jedi."
So we thought why
not just go back,
make a pilgrimage of sorts,
to where George Lucas filmed.
And here I am in the desert.
And we got this shot down there
of Luke rescuing Chewbacca
and Han Solo from
Jabba the Hutt.
And we didn't know
this, but it's
incredibly windy in the desert.
Maybe if you're from California,
that's like an obvious thing.
But you know, these images of
the desert seem quite tranquil,
but it's actually
violently windy out there.
So I managed to get my shot
before like my whole set blew
apart from the wind.
Chewbacca fell over
and broke the set.
And in fact, there
were parts of the set
that fell down into a dune.
It's like, I don't know if
you've ever walked a dune,
but it's kind of hard to go
all the way down 30, 40 feet
into the dune and walk back up.
And there just happened to
be a couple of ATV riders
bombing around in that area.
And they were nice enough to go
and fetch some of these pieces
for me.
And even though California
does have desert,
there's somethings
you can't find.
And that is desert-- at
least we couldn't find it.
We didn't know
where it was-- flat
desert all the way
to the horizon.
The images that you
know of Tatooine,
those were done in
Tunisia by George Lucas.
And so here, we are in Arizona.
And there's like cactuses
everywhere and mountains.
And so we knew we weren't
going find any flat desert.
So we just decided
to just dummy it up
with a couple of cardboard
boxes and a little bit of sand.
And that wound up being
the cover of "A New Hope."
And there, we just
created the illusion
of that Tunisian desert.
OK, so that's the
end of my discussion
about how we made the books.
I just want to talk a little
bit more about my career change
and come to this principle
called ride mule chase horse.
And that's a literal translation
of a Chinese proverb.
And it means just hang
on to what you have
while you're looking
for something better.
And even more directly,
don't quit your day job.
Your mule is your day job, and
the horse is the dream job.
And for me, when I was
making the transition,
I was moonlighting as a
children's Illustrator
for three years before
I gave up my day job.
And even today, I can't say
that I've made it, made it
as a children's Illustrator.
I might have to go and get
a real job again sometime.
I'm not sure.
I hope to do this
as long as I can.
But just when
you're starting out,
especially if you're
down-shifting-- someone like me
who had a well-paying,
high-stress time-consuming
job-- if you want to
downshift, sometimes people
think that the best
way to do that is
to just throw it all away.
OK, I'm quitting today.
I'm done.
I'm going to go and
pursue my dream.
But you know, the
research actually
shows if you're kind
of A type personality,
you sort of strive on
a little bit of stress,
you can actually be bored if
you're just quitting your job
and you're not sure exactly
what you're going to move onto.
You're going to feel
the loss of status
and the loss of financial
freedom very acutely.
So you're probably better
off taking on more than less.
So that's what I wound
up doing for three years,
is I actually took on more.
So I had very young children.
I was working as a lawyer and
basically used all my free time
on evenings and weekends to
work on the Cozy Classics books
to try to get that started.
So in those first
two and a half years,
I only got two books done
because I didn't have much time
to do them.
But it was certainly
an outlet for me.
I think that when you have a
day job that sometimes you're
a little bit frustrated by,
you actually have more energy
to put into your side pursuits.
If that becomes
your main pursuit,
then maybe you're
not using that energy
that you get from being
frustrated from your day job
and pouring it
into your sideline.
So I mean, that was a really
healthy energy for me to have,
is like I was really
motivated to work
on the needle felting projects.
Because somewhere in
the back of my mind,
I knew it was kind of
crazy, but I thought, oh,
maybe a different life can come
from doing these children's
books.
And it seems so far fetched,
my wife thought I was crazy.
And fair enough.
You've got a busy life and
you're spending your time
needle felting.
But it has worked
out well for me.
I had the great pleasure
of doing a Google
doodle this February.
I don't know if some of
you remember this or not,
but it is from February 17
commemorating Laura Ingalls
Wilder's birthday.
She, of course, of "Little
House on Prairie" fame
And same kind of idea.
Here's some behind
the scenes photos.
Here I am making that
prairie landscape.
Again, we wanted to
find this in Vancouver,
but we don't have this kind
of landscape in Vancouver.
So we were forced to build it.
And there's my brother building
the actual little house.
Here we are doing
interior test shots.
And then finally,
we took it outside
to shoot with natural lighting.
And it was January
that we did this,
so the light was
very low in the sky.
So I had to tilt the whole set
to get a more summery angle
of light because it
would immediately
seem odd to have sun coming
at a very low angle for this.
And so we actually
got bumped for a year.
We were ready to go for 2014,
and then they said, oh, well,
we have a conflict.
So we're going to have to
put you guys off to 2015.
And we were kind of
bummed about that.
So our idea is, well, if
the parents already love
the stories-- "Pride and
Prejudice," "Star Wars"--
maybe they'll present these
books with just that extra bit
of enthusiasm.
And that will make kids
love books, love reading,
and hopefully just be a good
first step into a lifetime
of loving books.
So thank you very
much for your time.
This is the last image
from "Empire Strikes Back,"
of course.
It's paired with
the word "goodbye,"
which is apropos for today.
And I'd be very pleased
to take any questions
if anybody has any.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So with the Princess
Leia, the different hairdos,
[INAUDIBLE]?
HOLMAN WANG: For Princess
Leia, she had kind of a--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sorry, could
you repeat the question?
HOLMAN WANG: Oh, yes.
The question is, how did you
recreate Princes Leia's hair?
And did you have to have
different versions of her head
or of her hair?
What I basically did was had
a very flat base of brown hair
to her head, and then I would
add extra pieces to that.
So the buns could be
added and removed.
Various kinds of braids
and as that sort of thing
were added and removed.
But she had kind of a flat
base of brown felt on her head.
But it was the same Leia head.
Some of these felt figures
take quite a beating
while they go through
the process of making
a book because you're sort
of taking things apart
and putting them back on, yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How [INAUDIBLE]
to work with your brother?
HOLMAN WANG: Well, my brother
and I-- I worked on "Star Wars"
full-time And he still had a
day job as a writing professor
at the college.
So we both did the
needle felting,
although I did
the heavy lifting.
But we both created
the felt figures.
And I did the set building and
the photography in Vancouver.
And because he's the
writing professor,
he's the one who takes the
first crack at the words.
And it seems a little bit silly.
It's like, oh, well, how hard
can it be to write 12 words?
But we actually had to go
through many rounds of editing,
if you can believe it,
for those 12 words.
Because it's almost like
if you have fewer words,
you have to get
them perfect, right?
Because they have
to do a lot of work.
They have to describe an image.
They have to move
the narrative along.
They have to express
Star Wars-y terms.
So my brother and I went through
our own rounds of hashing out
what the words would be.
Then we had a round of
editing with Chronicle Books
and our editors there.
And then finally, we had
a round with Lucas Film.
So for example, the very first
picture in "Return of the Jedi"
is an image of R2-D2
and C3PO just in desert,
just the two of them.
And the word was
"robots" originally
because we thought, well, that's
the simplest word for children.
And Lucas Films said no,
we need the word "droids,"
which is fair enough
because that's what is used.
But we just thought, well,
if kids are going to say,
what's a droid, you're going
to say, well, they're robots.
But they can learn
"droids" first.
That's perfectly fine.
So there's those kinds
of considerations
that go into figuring out what
the words should be, yeah.
AUDIENCE: When Jack
came up with the idea
about let's do these
books in so many words,
had you guys already been
needle felting as a hobby?
Or how did that come into being?
HOLMAN WANG: Right.
So the question is
when my brother came up
with the concept
for Cozy Classics,
had we ever done
any needle felting?
The answer's no.
We had no experience
whatsoever in needle felting.
I had just seen my sister-in-law
make some small animals
or pieces of fruit.
And it was just very
tangentially introduced
to even the concept
needle feting.
Many people, when I
tell them I needle felt,
they don't know anything
about the technique at all.
So it's still gaining
in popularity.
But I just thought
it might be something
that I could try my
hand at and see if I
could create little figures.
And basically, it's been
a lot of trial and error
to learn the techniques
that we have.
I mean, certainly, if
for some crazy reason,
we were offered "Star Wars"
as the first needle felting
project, it would've been
a very different project
than what it is now.
We sort of cut our teeth a
little bit on Cozy Classics.
Like, the very first
Cozy Classics books,
you'll see subtle differences.
For example, certain characters
don't even have eyebrows.
They don't have thumbs.
They don't have three
dimensional ears.
OK, yeah, sure.
Yeah, great, perfect.
So we had to learn a lot of
different-- sort of teach
ourselves different
techniques and things improved
over time to the point that
we could execute on something
like "Star Wars."
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HOLMAN WANG: So the
question is, is that also
the case with the
photography and model making?
And absolutely, yeah.
I would say yes.
It's interesting because with
Cozy Classics and our first two
books, you can look at them.
There's definitely a
very strong justification
for keeping things very
simple because children
who are very young,
they can't necessary
process a lot visually.
So you want to keep
things very simple.
So there's a kind of charm
about the simplicity and maybe
even crudeness of some of
the work at the beginning.
It works quite well.
But then when you get
to a Star Wars universe,
people expect to see
certain things, right?
And so it became a much
more complicated process
of replicating something
just as people know it.
Because "Star Wars," of
course, it's a classic,
but it's a visual text, whereas
with classics like "Pride
and Prejudice," people
might have an idea of what
things look like.
But you have a lot more license
to create things the way
you want.
And so "Star Wars"
was definitely
a challenge of replicating
a visual text that people
are going to be very,
very protective of, right?
So yeah, our techniques
definitely improved.
I'm also a self-taught
photographer as well.
So in terms of those
techniques, certainly had
to improve on those.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why the needling
felting as opposed
to like clay? [INAUDIBLE]?
HOLMAN WANG: The question is
why needle felting as opposed
to clay or some other way.
To us, it just really seemed
like we needed a technique that
would, one, be appropriate
for very young children
but that would be interesting
for adults to look at.
And that could be clay, but we
have seen clay artists before
in doing children's books.
And it seemed a little
bit fresher for us
to do needling felting.
And the plushness
seemed to be something
that would be appropriate for
very, very young children,
whereas the hand-craft
aspect was something
that adults would appreciate.
So we were kind
of creating books
with a whole range
of audiences in mind.
And we were reviewed in
"Apartment Therapy" recently,
and they said "Star Wars" books
are-- and it said age group.
It said 1 to 100.
And that's very gratifying
because they got it.
These books are really
for any age group.
And needle felting
for us was just,
we thought, a technique that
really offered something
for everybody, yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How long does
it take [INAUDIBLE]?
HOLMAN WANG: Yeah, the
question is, how long does it
take to make the figures?
The really complicated ones--
Chewbacca, Darth Vader--
are on the order of like
50 or 60 hours to make.
And the smaller ones, like
a little Ewok or Yoda,
would probably be
more around 20 hours.
So it's very labor intensive.
It's very labor intensive, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HOLMAN WANG: Pardon me?
AUDIENCE: Another revenue
stream might be to sell those.
HOLMAN WANG: Yeah,
people-- the question
is about selling the figures.
Many people ask about
buying the figures,
and we would have to--
well, first of all,
we're not allowed to sell them.
But even if we were,
they would have
to be one-off art
pieces that would-- I
wouldn't part with them except
for some exorbitant amount
of money.
Because I put so much time
and love into them, so yeah.
OK, well, thank you all
very much for your time.
I really appreciate it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Great, thank you, Holman.
Any last questions
before we wrap up?
AUDIENCE: Are there any
other [? dramas ?] or stories
that you would ever
want to pursue?
[INAUDIBLE]
HOLMAN WANG: Right.
The question is are there
other kinds of books
that we want to adapt?
We certainly have lots of ideas
about what we'd like to do.
We're doing more Cozy Classics,
so we're doing more things
in the public domain.
We're working on "The
Nutcracker" right now.
The "Wizard of Oz" is
coming out in 2017.
So those projects are-- and
right now, our Cozy Classics
are with a Vancouver publisher.
But they're all going to be
reissued by Chronicle Books
next year.
So woo-hoo, that's awesome.
We're really happy to be
moving over to Chronicle
with Cozy Classics.
There are other
things that we would
like to adapt, something like
the "Chronicles of Narnia,"
"Harry Potter," "Little Pie in
the Sky," something like that.
Right now, for us,
the question is, do we
want to do more licensed
projects, or whether we want
to create something on our own.
Because I think our felt
figures might lend themselves
to creating our own
universe of characters
that people can love directly,
not just be derivative
of another franchise.
So that's our
question right now--
is whether we want to
embark on that project
and create our own
universe of characters.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great,
thank you so much.
It was a great presentation.
We hope you have you back soon.
HOLMAN WANG: Thank
you very much.